a lot of people tell me how mature I am
but it's from you I'm humble's brother
God bless you what are you working on
now mentally like that's the biggest
challenge for you I mean dude Life's
good like I have an agency I do this now
if you're in this place make sure you're
committed to making other people happy
yeah that's the next step for you to be
this young in that place yeah now you
have a responsibility like I did yeah I
know bro it's scary because it's like
it's like I make the most out of anyone
in my whole family like I put my brother
on my brother makes good money now like
now I gotta take care of my parents I'm
like proud of you it's good bro howdy I
love you bro strangers too yeah show
them the love